dominic cummings says he thinks the
prime minister has acted illegally
what's your view the the truth of the
matter is
we don't know the truth and we've got
scrapping between
two very powerful men who seem more
interested in
who's lying about what and who's leaking
what than the substantive
of the issue and that is that whether
contracts get given out by text messages
whether tax breaks get given out by text
messages
or whether the prime minister uses his
pals to get money to
have his flat down up the whether i back
dominic cummings view or boris johnson's
view what what we need is
a proper independent inquiry where it
isn't about two boys fighting and is
about taxpayers in our country but in
in seeking to get an answer to these
questions is the labour party going to
ask for an urgent question in parliament
this week
i believe so uh i should very much
imagine that is the case as we return to
parliament tomorrow um but whether we
get the answers because boris johnson
will often say one thing at the dispatch
box if it is even boris johnson or rishi
sooner
or their junior ministers who they often
send out to
to fight these battles for them whether
we actually get answers that then
meter out to any real transparency or
integrity in the long run
it is is very difficult to say so we
need that urgent question we need
members of parliament to
to not think necessarily on party lines
but to be going after
all of us uh in parliament and all of us
in politics
uh integrity really really matters and
so we've got to ask those questions so
that people in the country can trust us
with their lives um but we need an
independent inquiry
into this this needs to be properly root
and branch
not the prime minister calling up his
best friends in their
different newspapers to have a pop up
dominick comings and dominic cummings
touring round select committees or
writing blog posts
this we need to take this out of the
hands of the people who frankly have got
questions
to ask kirsten did say in the comments
uh this week that this is all about
sleesley sleeves but
the reality is that if labor were in
government and i need when labour were
in government
you would have been lobbied you would
have faced very very similar accusations
well i i can't say that we would have
faced very similar accusations but what
the labour party
is asserting to do now would be a rule
that we all have to live by and
you know this isn't this is about what
is happening right now
and the contracts that have been given
out unfairly
it seems to businesses who can just get
in touch with the prime minister
no one's saying that people can't lobby
what shouldn't
happen is that people shouldn't be
lobbying for commercial gain for them
and their mates and that businesses in
my constituency should be able to lobby
just as easily to get contracts
to provide things that our country needs
as boris johnson's pals
but is it is it lobbying is it sleaze if
if what dyson was doing was
was an employer checking that that his
employees not him personally his
employees wouldn't be worse off
if they did something that they were
being asked to do by the government
that's not slaves that's just good
management isn't it well it's good
management that's not available to
anyone in my constituency so during the
pandemic there were lots of
organizations in my constituency that
had to change there were lots of
individuals who had to change tax
arrangements for example
people who went back to work on bank
shifts in the nhs their tax brackets
would have changed
did any of them have the text access to
the prime minister
it's it whether you know it people do
things via text it has to be
open that that is what is happening and
so when my companies in birmingham
yardley
want to look at contracts for ppe or
ventilators which
many of them did i was given a generic
email address
for them to email which led to
absolutely nothing if only
you know i could have been in a whatsapp
group sending gifts to the prime
minister
um peter mandelson pointed out this week
that skewering the tories over sleeves
which obviously
labour is keen to do won't be enough to
win the 2024 election
it doesn't seem necessarily to be
cutting through at the moment if we look
at the latest
uh opinion poll it gives the
conservatives an 11 point lead
over labor despite all of these negative
stories and
boris johnson a 41 approval rating uh
kiestarma 33
it's it's not great is it that given all
of these stories over the last couple of
weeks
labour are still lagging this far behind
the truth of the matter is they don't
wish to
skewer boris johnson for electoral gain
i wish to secure him as a
taxpayer and somebody who i want to see
politics
uh being made honest so that people can
trust politicians and feel part of our
system again
but you know what you're saying is it's
a totally fair
uh assessment of the situation but we're
in a pandemic times and
and kiyosama has taken over the labor
party which was in a terrible position
in a very very difficult time where the
country is focused on
getting back to work getting to feel
healthy getting to feel like they can
cuddle their families
without being frightened of catching a
disease it's not a surprise that
opposition politics
is is difficult at this time but there's
there's a long time before uh the 2024
uh election and if i was to be
completely honest i don't want to skewer
boris johnson i want him to be better
i want him to be better for my
constituents i want him and his pals
having a fallout
and him and his pals giving each other
contracts
because they're showing off to each
other about who's the most powerful
that's the thing i want to skewer here
we saw this week kierstarma in front of
the cameras he had a really awkward
encounter in a pub
didn't he um where the landlord um
wanted to present him with some
information and then didn't want him in
the problem
at all um what did he think of of that
encounter and do you think that the
central exchange was
a central charge of what the landlord
said to mr salma was that
he's failed to hold the government to
account did do you feel that he's held
the government
feet to the fire enough yes i do think
he's
helped the government i i don't agree
with the the the thrust of what the
public um was saying
as if somehow lockdowns um
are weren't necessary and in fact in the
papers today there's all sorts of things
about whether boris johnson
uh terrible things he's alleged to have
said maybe by dominic cummings who knows
about whether we have lockdowns
regardless of the amount of people who
died there was a there was a
simple thing that had to be done we had
to stop the virus and i don't agree with
the republican
on on that but the idea that we haven't
held the government to account the
government has u-turned
many times throughout this crisis and
it's not fair to say that that isn't
because of the actions
of the likes of kirsten and his team the
sleaze uh conversation that we're having
is a partnership between very good uh
investigative journalism um and
rachel reeves on the labour front bench
has been saying this again
and again not just after these recent
revelations but for the last year
and and their feet are held to the to
the fire but do you think i mean looking
at how
how kirstarma dealt with that you know
he didn't interact he tried to walk away
and then he then
then did interact it's these kind of
situations and election campaigns are
always a test of instinct
aren't they um do you think he does have
the right instinct because if we look at
sort of the red wall seats and
and we look at you know the west
midlands area where you are the
conservatives are still doing better
shouldn't
labor have cut through by now i'm not
sure that if i don't know
kirsten has tried to lamp the landlord
that we will
be coming forward
to be honest i think he was incredibly
calm
in the face of a difficult situation
which is actually what i want from my
leaders
i don't want when they're faced with
challenge that they start ringing around
journalists to to have a pop of their
mates to say it isn't the difficult
times we should be focusing on it's
because seven says said seven so about
seven said
you know actually what i want to see
from my leader and what i think cuts
through from that exchange about kia
stammer is that he is a calm and safe
pair
of hands uh and all power to him
uh you know i'm not sure i would have
been so calm